>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR OUR
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE
PEER BEHIND THE BIG CULTURE
STORIES OF THE DAY, THIS WEEK
IN HISTORY.
I'M JOINED NOW BY FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR OF THE WILL WHILE
THERE SERIOUS, FIRST BET
FEATURED A RESPONSE TO THE STATE
OF THE UNION A DAY AFTER THE
>> Laura: THIS WAS ANGELA RYE
WHO WAS INTRODUCING MAXINE.
>> IN CASE YOU MISSED THE STATE
OF THE UNION, SPOILER ALERT, YOU
MISSED NOTHING.
WE WANT TO SPEND ALL OF OUR TIME
TOGETHER LAMENTING THE WALKING
DISASTER THAT THIS THE KKK'S
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
SHE DELIVERS A REBUTTAL THAT
WILL SEAL THE LID ON THAT
[BLEEP] THAT DONALD TRUMP CALLS
A MOUTH.
>> WHENEVER HE APPEARS ON TV,
THERE SHOULD BE A DISCLAIMER
THAT SAYS THIS MAY NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE FOR CHILDREN.
>> SHE SHOULD'VE HAD THE
DISCLAIMER FOR THE HOST OF THE
SHOW.
WHERE'S HER DISCLAIMER?
WHAT WAS THAT?
>> I THOUGHT THEY WANTED TO LIVE
IN THE PARKING LOT OF THE
CAPITAL.
>> Laura: LOOK AT THAT, I
DIDN'T EVEN UNDERSTAND THAT.
LET'S WATCH THE NEXT ONE.
>> HE'S NOT PRESIDENTIAL AND HE
NEVER WILL BE PRESIDENTIAL.
HE CLAIMS THAT HE IS BRINGING
PEOPLE TOGETHER BUT MAKE NO
MISTAKE, HE IS A DANGEROUS
UNPRINCIPLED DIVISIVE AND
SHAMEFUL RACIST.
WE DESERVE BETTER, THAT'S WHY I
HAVE CALLED FOR HIS IMPEACHMENT.
SOME BELIEVE IT'S TOO EARLY, I
DISAGREE.
THE TIME IS NOW.
>> WHAT DO YOU AFTER THAT?
>> THEY SHOULD HAVE A NUMBER FOR
ALL OF THE INSULTS.
WHY SAY IT ALL AT THIS POINT?
>> IF YOU'RE GOING TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
GROUNDS.
I DON'T LIKE HIM, HE'S MEAN, THE
OTHER THING -- THIS IS BLACK
ENTERTAINMENT TELEVISION.
>> Laura: IS SORT OF
ENTERTAINING.
>> Sean: I WOULD'VE PREFERRED
MADIA DOING POLITICAL
COMMENTARY.
MEL GIBSON IS GOING TO DO THE
SEQUEL TO THE PASSION OF THE
CHRIST WHICH MADE MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS.
>> $600 MILLION, ONE OF THE
BIGGEST R-RATED FILMS OF ALL
TIME.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO THE
RESURRECTION, HOW DOES THIS COME
ABOUT?
>> JIM CAVIEZEL DID AN INTERVIEW
TODAY, HE SAID THIS IS GOING TO
BE THE BIGGEST MOVIE OF ALL TIME
BE THE BIGGEST MOVIE OF ALL TIM
TIME.
"THE TODAY SHOW" SET HAS
MEL GIBSON REALLY BEEN FORGIVEN?
THE GUY WON A GOLDEN GLOBE LAST
YEAR FOR HACKSAW BRIDGE.
WITH, IS WONDERING WHETHER
MEL GIBSON HAS BEEN FORGIVEN?
LET'S WATCH WHAT MEL SAID ABOUT
THE RESURRECTION.
>> IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT A
RESURRECTION, IT'S NOT THE MAN
COMES BACK TO WALK THROUGH
WALLS, HAS HOLES IN HANDS, IT'S
NOT THAT.
IT'S A VAST THEOLOGICAL
EXPERIENCE.
I THINK WE NEED TO DELVE INTO
WHAT THAT MEANS IN A WAY THAT
YOU TAKE AS THE CENTERPIECE AND
YOU JUXTAPOSE IT AGAINST MANY
PRETTY WILD.
IT'S LIKE AN ACID TRIP.
YOU HAVE A SPIRIT GUIDE TO TAKE
YOU THROUGH IT.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHY THEY CALL
HIM MAD MAX.